[Music]
you know this is the 30th anniversary
this month of Princess Bride what do you
think about that bubble you'll give us
in 2/4 I don't think I miss what you're
thinking miss I forgot about that you
forgot I thought we made it yesterday
it's yeah every time anybody mentions it
I I just can't get over that it's had
the life that it said because we just
went to work 30 years ago did our best
and had a great time and then that it's
become what it's become for all these
generations I pinch myself any time even
when you just said it that oh he's
talking about that movie are you no one
of consequence
I must get used to disappointment
generation after generation gets to meet
you through that movie yes I don't know
what more you could ask for when
grandparents tell their grandchildren
that's the guy in and the kid looks at
me like the grandfather's crazy and then
I whisper in the kid's ear hello my name
is inigo montoya what's your favorite
memory working on that movie well all of
them I know and we all stay in touch
Carrie and I especially
you're alive if you want I can flood me
it feels like we made it five ten years
ago it never feels as long as it's been
because we really bonded all of us and
what a great piece to be a part of
[Music]